Générique
-100 ans après les derniers
Jeux Olympiques d'été,
Paris accueille
à nouveau les JO,
avec un objectif : figurer
dans le top 5 des médailles.
-Ce rendez-vous arrivera
une fois dans votre vie.
Vous le savez.
-Nos sportifs sont nos héros.
Leurs performances,
leurs victoires
font notre fierté.
Et pourtant, rares sont ceux
qui vivent de leur sport.
-On va pas passer son temps
à vomir et à courir sur la piste
comme des malades,
pour quelque chose
qui ne rapporte pas.
-Aux Jeux Olympique de Rio,
en 2016,
40 % des athlètes français vivaient
sous le seuil de pauvreté.
Dans ces conditions,
comment atteindre l'objectif
fixé par le président ?
-Quand l'athlète sait
qu'à la fin du mois,
elle est payée,
surtout en cette année,
ça n'a pas de prix.
-A quelques mois
des premières épreuves,
comment la France accompagne-t-elle
la préparation des athlètes ?
Va-t-elle tenir son objectif ?
...
Musique intense
Depuis 2020,
la France a mis en place
un plan
pour aider
les plus grands espoirs
de médaille.
Une politique élitiste assumée,
inspirée du Royaume-Uni.
10 ans avant les JO de Londres,
le sport britannique a investi
massivement sur ses champions,
avec un seul objectif :
les podiums.
Pour 2024,
la France a misé prioritairement
sur 272 athlètes.
-Pauline Ranvier,
29 ans,
vice-championne olympique d'escrime
de fleuret par équipe
aux JO de Tokyo,
vice-championne
en individuel cette année,
et je prépare
les JO de Paris 2024.
-Pauline est l'une des meilleures
fleurettistes de sa génération.
Elle a intégré
le Cercle Haute Performance,
le meilleur dispositif
d'accompagnement
des athlètes.
Elle a un suivi
haute couture.
A l'Insep,
la fabrique des champions,
elle s'entraîne
sans relâche,
pour viser
l'or olympique.
-On a la chance,
c'est vrai,
d'avoir tout
à disposition,
que ce soit...
J'utilise la préparation mentale.
Et aussi des gens qui sont
dans l'optimisation du geste.
La préparation physique...
Dès qu'on a un souci,
on est très, très vite
pris en charge.
Il y a des dispositifs mis en place,
car les Jeux sont à domicile.
On est plus aidés
et écoutés.
Ca montre
que la France aspire
à rentrer dans les meilleures
nations mondiales
au niveau
du sport de haut niveau.
-Pour la première fois,
Pauline est sûre
de toucher, au minimum,
40 000 euros par an,
pour préparer les Jeux.
Si elle ne les gagne pas
par ses propres moyens,
l'Agence nationale du sport
complétera.
-Aujourd'hui, j'ai pas à me soucier
d'aller travailler.
Je peux vivre de mon sport
et de mes sponsors.
-Depuis 2017,
Pauline a signé un contrat
avec l'armée,
qui lui verse
un SMIC par mois,
contre 20 jours
de présence par an.
-C'est l'armée,
l'armée de terre,
qui me soutient depuis 2017,
qui est vraiment
une aide énorme
depuis toutes ces années.
Et puis récemment,
j'ai signé avec la BPCE
sur un pack de performances.
Avec la mutuelle MGC.
Et j'ai aussi l'eau thermale
d'Avène, qui m'aide.
J'ai aussi une catégorie
qui s'appelle Sport Models,
une agence de mannequinat
qui fait des sportifs.
J'ai une personne qui s'appelle
Jérôme Petitguyot,
qui m'aide aussi
via son entreprise.
Et évidemment mon club,
mon département,
et donc la région du 77.
-Sur la piste, sur 15 fleurettistes,
elles ne sont que 4 comme Pauline,
à se consacrer totalement
à leur préparation olympique.
-Je gène, je gène...
Tu es en train de passer.
Cuisse avant, là,
et ça va !
Ca va monter !
Je gène, il n'y a rien,
je redresse...
Et je peux le refaire.
La vraie nouveauté,
c'est qu'avant même d'être champion,
dans les "starts",
on accompagne.
On met tout en oeuvre
pour que nos athlètes,
nos médaillables,
comme on les appelle,
soient
dans les meilleures conditions.
C'est un plus incroyable.
Ceux qui ont pas
la chance d'être accompagné
ont souvent tendance
à s'éparpiller un petit peu.
Ils vont chercher
un sponsor...
Lorsqu'on est accompagné
dès le début,
cette sérénité,
on l'acquiert
beaucoup plus facilement.
Elle est indispensable.
Pas suffisante
mais indispensable.
-Je m'estime chanceuse
de pouvoir
faire partie de la génération
qui a ce dispositif.
Je m'en suis
donné les moyens.
Pouvoir y accéder...
J'ai la chance de vivre
de ma passion...
Ca, c'est top.
-Pauline fait partie
de ce cercle privilégié
car elle a remporté
une médaille lors des derniers
championnats du monde.
Pour financer l'ambition
française
et ces dispositifs,
l'Agence nationale du sport
a été dotée
de 120 millions d'euros,
mais elle a encore besoin de l'aide
et de financements
des entreprises.
Musique douce
...
-On devrait être au complet.
-Une vingtaine d'entreprises ?
-Une vingtaine d'entreprises.
On va répartir les gens
en fonction...
On met les intervenants
sur la table.
-Aujourd'hui,
Maguy Nestoret et Odile Pellegrino
vont les encourager
ou sponsoriser des sportifs.
-Merci à tous
de votre présence.
Ravie de vous accueillir ici pour
notre petit-déjeuner entreprises.
On va vous présenter comment
une entreprise peut accompagner
un sportif
de haut niveau.
Il s'agit d'optimiser
l'accompagnement des sportifs,
grâce à votre mobilisation.
Il y a l'Etat,
qui est très fortement impliqué
sur le sport
de haut niveau.
On a des administrations.
On a le ministère des Armées
qui accompagne plus
de 200 sportifs.
La police,
les douanes...
On a besoin
des entreprises.
-L'un des objectifs,
c'est de les encourager
à signer des CIP,
des conventions
d'insertion professionnelle,
avec les athlètes.
-Donc, le sportif,
il est salarié
de l'entreprise,
il signe un contrat de travail,
comme un salarié.
A ce contrat de travail,
on va venir
signer une convention qui va
aménager son temps de travail.
L'avantage de ce dispositif,
c'est qu'on peut venir apporter
une contrepartie
financière.
Que l'Agence verse
à l'entreprise
pour compenser
le manque à gagner employeur.
Quand le sportif n'est pas
à l'entreprise,
vous le payez à 100 %.
Le sportif a besoin
de ces revenus.
On vient compenser
cette perte financière,
pour que vous libériez le sportif
dans les meilleures conditions.
-EDF est l'une des entreprises
les plus engagées
dans l'accueil des sportifs.
Elle emploie
l'athlète paralympique
Alexandra Nouchet
depuis plusieurs années.
Elle peut se préparer au 100 mètres
et au saut en longueur.
-Je suis en appui sur les missions
de la communication
interne, externe
et de l'événementiel
au sein de l'entreprise.
Au sein de mon équipe,
tout simplement.
J'ai décidé de faire l'équivalent
d'une demi-journée au travail,
et le reste,
je le dédie au sport.
J'ai pas à me soucier
de l'apport financier
et tout simplement,
je sais qu'après avoir
obtenu plein de médailles,
je le souhaite,
je vais pouvoir reprendre
mon activité professionnelle,
comme mes collègues.
Acclamations
-Merci beaucoup, Alexandra !
-Au-delà du premier
Cercle de Haute Performance,
l'Agence nationale du sport
a décidé d'élargir
les aides à plus
de 300 sportifs supplémentaires,
les plus potentiellement
médaillables.
-On a identifié des athlètes.
Des cellules prioritaires.
Des athlètes médaillés
sur les 2 dernières saisons.
Ils ont un fort potentiel
de médaille.
Ces athlètes,
on a déjà la garantie
qu'ils atteindront
40 000 euros de revenus brut
sur une année complète.
Ces athlètes,
on sait qu'ils sont
un peu plus de 500.
Après, il y a le reste
de la délégation.
On les emmène pas
aux 40 000 euros,
mais s'assurer qu'ils sont
au-dessus du seuil de pauvreté.
Il y a une liste qui existe.
Quand on a des athlètes
avec de grosses difficultés,
la priorité est
de les accompagner
pour les sortir
de cette situation.
-Le seuil de pauvreté,
c'est 1150 euros par mois
pour vivre.
Ce jour-là, plusieurs entreprises
ont été séduites.
-On est vraiment
à la réflexion.
C'est une découverte,
ce dispositif existant.
Pourquoi pas accueillir
des sportifs ?
-On a eu plein de détails utiles.
On a aussi une meilleure idée
de ce qu'on peut proposer,
de ce qu'ils attendent.
-On vous envoie tout.
OK ? Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
-Au revoir.
-Merci, au revoir.
-De grands groupes se sont déjà
saisis de l'intérêt des Jeux.
Plus de 40 ont composé
leur team d'athlètes
qu'ils financent.
C'est le cas
de Carrefour.
Ce matin, Auriane Mallo
a rendez-vous
avec les équipes
du supermarché de Villabé,
dans l'Essonne.
-Bonjour, Auriane !
-Bonjour !
-Enchantée.
-Marc Truchot, directeur.
Bienvenue !
-Auriane Mallo, 30 ans.
Equipe de France d'épée.
Quadruple
championne d'Europe
par équipe.
3e aux championnats d'Europe
en individuel.
L'objectif est clair,
cette année :
rapporter les plus belles médailles
en individuel et par équipe.
-Il y a un an,
Auriane a intégré
la team Carrefour.
Une chance,
juste avant les Jeux,
car avant,
elle avait un CIP.
Elle était kiné
4 demi-journées
par semaine.
Un rythme
difficilement compatible
avec une préparation
olympique.
Grâce à Carrefour,
elle a arrêté de travailler
et se prépare sereinement,
entre ses entraînements
et sa vie de maman.
-C'est hyper important
de se souvenir que moi,
sans Carrefour,
je serais obligée
de travailler.
C'est hyper important
de pouvoir venir échanger.
Ca me donne plein d'énergie
de savoir aussi que, voilà,
j'ai du monde avec moi.
-Carrefour soutient 14 athlètes,
grâce à une bourse de mécénat.
Ils leur versent chaque année
une dotation,
entre 20 et 30 000 euros,
défiscalisée
à 60 %.
En échange, le sportif participe
à quelques opérations d'image.
-On va à la boucherie.
On va vous faire...
On va vous montrer
notre manière de travailler.
-Les équipes ont préparé
à Auriane un "Vis ma vie",
sous l'oeil d'un photographe.
-Faut pas que je l'écrase trop.
-Oui. Parfait.
-C'est une première.
C'est super sympa de pouvoir
m'initier à la boucherie.
-Je tends ma ficelle,
je fais deux boucles,
je serre...
-Allez, c'est parti.
-On essaye.
-T'es passé
de l'autre côté...
C'est pas le bon, là.
Un dernier pour la route.
-Une médaillée d'or,
ça peut être qu'un honneur,
pour nous, Carrefour...
Franchement, c'est top.
Trop bien. Très, très bien.
-Pour nos équipes,
c'est important,
c'est valorisant
d'avoir,
peut-être, des futurs
médaillés olympiques,
c'est une belle image.
C'est un bon moment pour
nos collaborateurs.
-Certains sportifs n'ont pas
la chance de rentrer
dans ce dispositif.
-Merci !
Ravie d'être venue vous voir !
-En athlétisme,
un seul champion a intégré
le Cercle Haute Performance.
La politique française
est soumise aux résultats,
à des carrières régulières,
sans blessure, ce qui est rare,
quand on doit travailler
pour vivre sa passion.
-David Sombé,
athlète spécialisé
sur le 400 mètres
et le 4x400.
Cet été, j'irai chercher les JO,
la médaille peut-être,
et le record de France.
C'est mon quotidien.
-Vous courez par deux.
Au couloir 2 et 3.
Cherchez à déclencher.
Prêts ?
Top !
-Allez, allez, allez !
-ALLEZ, LES GARS !
-David est un des espoirs
du sprint français.
Pourtant, il y a un an,
pour vivre,
il était déménageur.
-Quand t'es déménageur...
C'est bien de dire
qu'il faut se baisser,
fléchir les jambes,
mais à longueur de journée,
tu le fais pas.
Quand tu prends
des pianos,
ou des photocopieurs
de 300-400 kilos,
ça défonce
ton corps.
-David devait s'entraîner seul
sur le stade
après des journées remplies.
Il a choisi
d'arrêter de travailler
et cela change tout
à ses performances.
-Se sentir soutenu,
à l'entraînement,
ça permet de se transcender,
de se pousser...
-On s'entraîne pas
forcément plus,
dans la quantité,
mais on a réparti l'ensemble
des choses qui sont faites
pour, du coup,
de la meilleure qualité.
Il dort mieux.
Il a moins de stress.
Il assimile mieux
les séances.
C'est des bienfaits
sur tous les niveaux.
J'ai capté la fatigue
mais c'est un bon temps.
Allez, viens.
On va marcher.
-En un an,
David a gagné plus
d'une seconde sur son record
du 400 mètres.
L'été dernier,
avec ses coéquipiers du relais,
ils ont remporté
la médaille d'argent
aux championnats du monde.
Musique douce
-C'est des très gros souvenirs.
Le Jamaïcain revient fort.
Si j'avais su qu'il était derrière,
j'aurais accéléré.
C'est des souvenirs de fou.
J'adore voir cette course.
-La seule médaille française
à Budapest, et pourtant,
David revient de loin.
En janvier 2023, il est sorti
des listes de haut niveau.
Trop blessé,
pas assez performant,
sa fédération cesse
toute aide financière.
-Ca a été difficile.
Le suivi financier
n'était plus le même.
On devait être
à 13 000 par an.
C'est pas fou.
A peine 1000 euros
par mois.
Ca fait douter du système.
Je voulais pas travailler
pour des gens qui pouvaient
me retirer
ce qui me nourrissait.
J'avais pas envie d'évoluer
dans ce système.
Je n'étais pas fait pour ça.
Ca, ça m'a...
Fait douter.
-Vous étiez prêt
à arrêter le sport ?
-Oui. Il faut du concret.
J'ai 23 ans.
J'habite avec madame
et sa mère.
Si l'athlé rapport pas,
c'est bien beau,
mais il y a une vie derrière.
On va pas passer son temps
à vomir et à courir
comme des malades
pour quelque chose
qui ne rapporte pas.
Il faut du concret.
-Tant qu'on est pas
à haut niveau,
l'accompagnement
est compliqué.
Soit il faut être suivi
très jeune,
à partir
de cadet, junior,
il peut y avoir un accompagnement,
des accès à des structures,
à des soins,
à des groupes d'entraînement.
Quand on arrive à bon haut niveau
à 21, 22, 23 ans,
c'est très difficile
d'ouvrir les portes.
C'est plus difficile.
Voilà.
Ce qu'il a réussi à faire à cet âge,
rentrer dans les listes,
en en étant sorti,
c'est plus compliqué.
-La fédération accompagne
au haut niveau.
On a eu la médaille.
A partir de là,
on est bien accompagnés.
C'est prévu.
-Jusqu'aux JO, David va percevoir
une aide personnalisée
pour vivre
de sa préparation olympique.
En décembre,
il a pu, pour la première fois,
partir avec l'équipe de France
en stage en Afrique du Sud.
Si David a pu intégrer in extremis
la cellule grâce à sa médaille,
certains sportifs en devenir
passent sous les radars
et se battent encore
pour boucler leur budget.
-Luca Barone.
Mon objectif : me qualifier
aux JO Paris 2024 en kayak,
et faire champion du monde
en 2024.
-OK...
Ready... Set... Go !
-Même pendant l'hiver,
on s'entraîne tous les jours.
Plusieurs fois par jour.
-Top !
-A la base,
je fais de la descente de rivière,
une discipline pas aux JO.
J'ai changé de discipline
depuis un an et demi
pour les Jeux.
-Luca espère se qualifier
sur le kayak en ligne.
Il compte mettre toutes les chances
de son côté.
Lui aussi a arrêté
de travailler.
Comme il a changé d'épreuve,
il n'est pas sur les listes
de haut niveau,
et ne reçoit pas d'aide
de sa fédération.
-Voilà, une de moins.
-Ouais.
C'était cool, hein.
J'ai pris un peu des repères.
-C'est son club
qui compense.
-Salut.
-Ca va ?
L'entraînement se passe bien ?
-Tout va bien.
Je viens de finir.
-Salut.
-On soutient au maximum
les athlètes.
En les aidant à s'acheter
tout le matériel.
Les pagayes, les bateaux,
qui sont très chers.
Cette année,
on a même dû participer
à la préparation des stages aux
championnats du monde et d'Europe
car la fédération
s'est désistée
financièrement,
par rapport aux athlètes.
-Une année de préparation
pour les Jeux,
cela coûte cher.
-A peu près 20 000 euros par an.
Le truc, c'est...
C'est uniquement
pour partir en stage,
pour aussi payer
les entraîneurs,
pour payer
la préparation mentale.
Ca, c'est pas mis à disposition
par la fédération.
-La fédé a déjà ciblé
certains athlètes.
Pour ceux comme Luca,
plutôt en devenir,
ils sont pas assez soutenus,
financièrement.
-On a l'impression
que c'est souvent du bricolage.
Pour nos athlètes...
Ils ont un état d'esprit
où ils s'adaptent.
C'est peut-être le problème.
Les athlètes français ont tendance
à s'adapter un peu trop.
Il y a d'autres disciplines
ou peut-être d'autres pays,
où j'ai l'impression
que c'est plus simple,
pour les athlètes,
de pouvoir performer
avec sérénité.
-Luca démarche seul
les entreprises
de sa région,
pour trouver des sponsors
et cela paye.
-Là, on va voir
un de mes partenaires.
Qui me suit depuis
un petit moment.
C'est à Cavaillon,
c'est Kookabarra,
une marque de jus de fruits.
J'ai d'autres sponsors mais eux
sont des partenaires
dont je suis proche.
Salut !
-Hello, Luca !
-Ca va ? Tu vas bien ?
-T'as la forme ?
-Super !
Super, tout va bien.
-Allez,
on va se boire
un petit jus ?
-Allez !
-Tu vas me raconter
où t'en es de ta préparation.
Ca va se passer comment,
la première compétition ?
-Hé bah, en mars.
Il faut être
dans les 2 meilleurs.
C'est ceux
qui vont aux Jeux.
-D'accord.
Il m'a contacté
via un réseau social,
Linkedin.
Le contact est bien passé.
Qu'il soit accompagné
par une fédé
ou pas, ça avait
rien à voir avec la démarche.
Moi, d'accompagner
des sportifs bien câblés,
avec la tête sur les épaules,
c'est une de mes missions
d'entreprise.
Ca va durer le plus
longtemps possible.
Quand j'entends
des jeunes talents
qui doivent faire le choix
entre leurs études ou leur sport,
c'est des choses
inconcevables.
-Jérémie Marcuccilli,
lui-même sportif,
connaît bien
la problématique.
Luca est l'un des ambassadeurs
de sa marque
autour de ses valeurs sportives.
Notamment sur les réseaux sociaux.
*-Mon partenaire Kookabarra.
Une entreprise avec laquelle
on partage des valeurs communes :
performance, partage...
-On s'est rencontrés, il y avait
Matthieu, notre photographe,
qui était ici.
Je lui ai dit que si on voulait
actionner le partenariat,
autant le faire tout de suite.
Il faisait beau.
On était en local,
le Rhône à côté,
il nous a dit "Go".
-Les réseaux sociaux,
c'est ce qui impacte
aujourd'hui,
le plus de monde.
En tant que sportif, pour essayer
de promouvoir soit son sport,
soit une image
en tant que sportif,
pour trouver des partenaires,
créer de la communauté.
-Luca parie sur les réseaux sociaux.
Sur Instagram,
il raconte son histoire,
à ses 6000 followers,
et essayent
d'agrandir
sa communauté.
*Musique dynamique
Certains sportifs tirent
leurs revenus
de leur image et leur contrat
sur les réseaux.
C'est là, que les marques
sont prêtes à dépenser.
-Matthias Dandois,
34 ans,
9 fois champion du monde
de BMX Flat.
-Matthias est un modèle dans
la façon d'envisager sa carrière
sur les réseaux.
-Salut !
-Salut, tu vas bien ?
-Ca va ? La forme ?
-Ouais !
-Ce jour-là, il fait le point
avec l'agence de conseil
Com'Over,
sur sa dernière campagne.
-Comment ça se passe ?
C'était le lancement ?
-Ouais, exactement.
-Ca s'est bien passé ?
-Super. Parfait.
-Avec les autres ?
-Très bien.
-Aujourd'hui, on peut être
un sportif de haut niveau,
et en vivre, sans monétiser
son image sur les réseaux ?
-Non.
Il y a un chiffre
dégueulasse en France.
Les sportifs de haut niveau
qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté,
c'est ouf.
Je pense que sans
les réseaux sociaux,
on peut pas vivre
de son sport en étant
sportif de haut niveau.
Point à la ligne.
-Les JO de Paris 2024 sont
un formidable levier.
Beaucoup d'opportunités
pour eux
de progresser à ce niveau,
de générer
des revenus en plus,
de gagner
en visibilité.
Le but est de bien le faire
pour que ce soit pas
un coup d'épée dans l'eau.
-David conseille les sportifs
et les fédérations
sur leur stratégie
et leur présence
sur les réseaux.
-Des gens seront
très à l'aise avec,
qui aiment
se mettre en image,
qui, comme Matthias, ont
des sports très visuels,
donc ça marche bien.
D'autres sont dans des disciplines
qui vont être niche,
qui vont être moins visuelles
à regarder,
ça va être plus difficile.
Ce qu'on recommande,
c'est d'essayer
de faire quelque chose
qui vous ressemble.
Mentir, ça se voit,
ça marche pas.
Quand on vient le chercher,
il faut qu'il soit à l'aise
avec ce qu'on va raconter,
et qu'il s'approprie
la prise de parole
sinon ça marche pas.
Pas bon pour lui
ni pour la marque.
-Les marques ont vachement
pris le pli
et elles ont un rôle
d'éducateur, maintenant.
Avec leurs teams d'athlètes.
J'ai des partenaires
avec qui je bosse,
chaque mois,
ils nous envoient
des PDF de ce qui marche
en ce moment sur Insta,
les choses cool à poster,
machin...
Ou même quand on fait
des "summits",
le moment où on se retrouve
tous à un endroit,
avec toute l'équipe,
il y a des présentations
hyper intéressantes
avec un mec d'Insta,
qui fait une présentation.
Ca nous donne des outils
pour mieux faire ce boulot
sur les réseaux sociaux.
-Aujourd'hui,
Matthias a plus de 300 000 followers
sur Instagram.
Une force de frappe qui lui permet
de choisir ses partenariats.
Il a créé sa société de production.
Il a le luxe d'être
maître de ses contenus
et d'y donner un sens.
-"Time Machine",
c'est un projet que j'ai imaginé
avec Red Bull et Swatch,
en 2021...
L'idée était de construire
un skatepark,
en forme de montre.
Une course contre le temps
pour gagner ce 10e titre
de champion du monde.
On a créé cet endroit où je me bats
un peu contre les aiguilles
qui tournent dans la vidéo.
Je "ride" dans la montre.
C'était un projet...
De... De dingue.
Voilà...
C'est pour ça
que les partenariats
avec les marques,
parfois,
ça crée des vidéos,
des projets incroyables,
qui vont servir l'athlète.
Musique hip hop
-Avec ses partenariats,
la diversification
de ses revenus,
Matthias a déjà
assuré son avenir.
Un modèle inspirant
pour de nombreux athlètes.
...
Derrière les têtes d'affiche,
pour la plupart
des sportifs français
de haut niveau,
vivre de sa discipline
et avoir les moyens
de s'entraîner reste
encore un parcours du combattant.
En misant tout
sur les athlètes confirmés,
la France a-t-elle fait
le bon choix ?
Il faudra attendre cet été
pour savoir
si cette nouvelle politique
a tenu ses promesses.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Musique intense
...